[Música]
aquí comienza ella soy de Francia 24 la
Corte Interamericana de Derechos Humanos
se reconoció que la violencia obstétrica
es violencia de género en el año 2019 la
Comisión Interamericana de Derechos
Humanos solicitó a la corte un
pronunciamiento sobre los derechos de
las personas privadas de la libertad
cuando éstas son mujeres embarazadas o
lactantes también solicitó opiniones
sobre los niños y las niñas que habitan
las prisiones con sus madres tres años
después la corte idh dio respuesta en un
informe de 166 páginas que incluye
además una parte importante sobre la
violencia obstétrica que se acentúa
cuando se viven maternidades en los
centros penitenciarios el tribunal dijo
que los estados deben dar a estas
mujeres condiciones diferenciales que
eviten la continuación de la
discriminación que también se vive en
las calles el documento también aboga
por las condiciones de mínimas que se
deben tener en cuenta a la hora de
gestionar la vida en prisión de la
población
lgbtiq más la población indígena y
también los adultos son mayores
vamos a conversar sobre este tema y Para
ello se conecta con nosotras desde
Madrid desde Barcelona España Marta
busquets Gallego ya es especialista en
derecho en género en salud y también en
derechos humanos es autora además de
múltiples publicaciones sobre género y
violencia obstétrica entre ellas se
destaca la violencia obstétrica en el
embarazo y el parto desde la perspectiva
de la vulneración de derechos con
autonomía y consentimiento Marta gracias
a usted por estar en ella soy y para
empezar quisiera preguntarle porque es
tan importante reconocer la violencia
obstétrica como una violencia de género
y si tiene relevancia que ese
reconocimiento lo haya hecho la corte
idh
Buenas tardes o buenos días dependiendo
de donde esté cada una es muy importante
este reconocimiento porque efectivamente
la violencia obstétrica tiene que ver
con la creencia de que los cuerpos
leídos como mujer los cuerpos de mujeres
no son válidos son defectuosos desde un
lugar en que se objetiviza nuestros
cuerpos no se nos considera sujetos de
los procesos por ejemplo de embarazo
parto posparto sino un objeto donde se
prioriza el hecho de que tenemos una
criatura en nuestro vientre Y entonces
solo atendemos a esta necesidad y En
definitiva donde se obvia que las
mujeres somos seres humanas completas
con agencia y derechos fundamentales y
al final una resolución de este tipo
siempre es una buena noticia porque
desgraciadamente sabemos que aunque las
mujeres vengamos quejándonos de que esto
sucede y en el caso de población reclusa
como este informe hace una gran
incidencia todavía hablamos de mujeres
en una situación de vulnerabilidad
todavía mayor es muy importante que
desde se le dé legitimidad a estas
quejas a este discurso a estos relatos
de violencia se puedan hacer
investigaciones se puedan recoger estas
vulneraciones y se pueda decir
claramente como hace este organismo no
que hay una vulneración de los Derechos
Humanos de las mujeres y que además
tenemos que poner la perspectiva de
género porque son vulneraciones
específicas que pasan porque se trata de
mujeres y en este caso que además son
mujeres reclusas y que el hecho de la
privación de libertad supone una
vulneración mayor de estos derechos
claro Es que para allá iba mi siguiente
pregunta porque si esto le sucede o le
puede suceder a cualquier mujer en su
vida y en el mundo en libertad Pues cómo
podría aumentar esa vulnerabilidad
cuando esta mujer Es una mujer que está
cumpliendo una sentencia de prisión
desgraciadamente de muchas maneras para
empezar Tenemos que tener en cuenta que
la población reclusa mujer representa un
porcentaje íntimo del porcentaje total
de población recursa por lo tanto
reclusa disculpad por lo tanto sucede
que a menudo las instalaciones
penitenciarias son más pequeñas están
más alejadas de sus centros y hay menos
recursos destinado a población
penitenciaria mujer pero es que luego
además con que nos encontramos con que
no hay profesionales sanitarios
especializados atendiendo en estas
facilidades con que tienen dificultades
como relatar el propio informe para
acceder a una nutrición adecuada a su
estado de salud que en este momento pues
puede ser embarazo parto posparto o
lactancia incluso cosas como acceder a
la ropa también sabemos y esto
desgraciadamente hay informes en todo el
mundo que se hace un uso no adecuado de
esposas y grilletes se hace traslados
por ejemplo a visitas médicas o incluso
hay mujeres que han relatado cada luz
con las esposas puestas Qué pasa cuando
una mujer en situación de embarazo
se la traslada por ejemplo aislamiento
que tiene un impacto en su en su salud
mental no todo esto y que hay que
tenerlo en cuenta porque normalmente las
mujeres que están en situación
penitenciaria pueden ser familias
monoparentales suelen tener personas a
su cargo etcétera y el hecho que además
estén recluidas las ponen una situación
muy delicadas a ella a toda su familia
las aristas de su entorno dificulta su
reinserción su vida entonces sufren
violencias específicas desgraciadamente
y ya ni hablemos por ejemplo de tener
protocolos actualizados de su
posibilidad de tomar decisiones su
derecho a la autonomía del
consentimiento informado de cómo quieren
llevar adelante su embarazo y su parto o
su posparto y lactancia claro y después
de eso de la lactancia y del periodo que
les permiten en muchos países a las
mujeres permanecer con sus hijos pues
Viene otro problemática un peor Y es que
va a pasar con esos niños cuando deban
ser trasladados desde el centro
penitenciario Y ser puestos en una
supuesta situación de protección de
derechos que Pues que muchas veces no
hay tal Y que tampoco tiene en cuenta la
madre Marta hablemos de Cómo reconocer
esta violencia obstétrica que va desde
por ejemplo el rechazo a las mujeres o
las críticas de los doctores a las
mujeres porque se quejan mientras que
están pariendo a sus hijos hasta
maniobras que realizan en ocasiones los
médicos o el personal médico que ponen
en peligro la vida de las mujeres y de
sus hijos
totalmente la violencia obstética tiene
muchas dimensiones tiene una dimensión
por ejemplo de intervenciones sanitarias
y aquí podríamos hablar de exceso de
cesta áreas exceso de intervenciones
como inducciones como pactos
instrumentales como instrumentalización
de rutina de partos Y luego tiene toda
la dimensión de Derechos Humanos También
tenemos que entender que precisamente
porque es una violencia de género parte
tiene que ver en parte con la negación
de la humanidad de las mujeres y de que
es un proceso que tiene que ver con
nuestros derechos sexuales y
reproductivos tanto embarazo parto
posparto y ya para muchas mujeres desde
el privilegio aún así sufrimos violencia
obstétrica porque se nos niega nuestra
capacidad de agencia nuestra capacidad
de tomar decisiones correctas sobre
nuestra salud la de nuestros hijos e
hijas nuestro embarazo parto en el caso
las mujeres reclusas es aún peor porque
ya hay un castigo social ya se considera
que han fallado como personas que le han
fallado sociedad están siendo castigadas
y a veces desde ahí ni tan solo se les
deja acceder a algo que se interpreta
como un premio para las buenas las
personas que serían sus derechos humanos
y no la realidad es que los Derechos
Humanos son para todas las personas que
estemos en la situación que estemos y
los Estados son garantes de que esto se
cumplan entonces Hay pocas situaciones
donde el estado decida todo en la vida
de una persona como puede ser por
ejemplo la situación de reclusión en un
centro penitenciario y el estado con más
motivo de debe garantizar que en sus
facilidades los derechos humanos de
todas sean operativos entonces muy
importante darnos cuenta de cómo no
estamos siendo tratadas como personas y
estamos siendo tratadas como objetos
cuando no se nos está dando nuestra
humanidad y nuestra agencia para algo
tan importante como es traer vida a este
mundo y Marta hay muchas violencias de
género muchos tipos de violencia de
género pero cuando se habla de la
violencia obstétrica puede haber un
atenuante que que que nos confunde y que
no nos permite luchar por nuestros
derechos y es que estamos en manos de
los médicos que nos venden que todo lo
que sucede en el proceso de parto o en
esta sala de parto a la que accedemos es
por nuestro bien y es natural y dentro
de ese discurso usted hablaba de la
inducción de partos se rompen Fuentes
sin permiso los médicos no sucede mucho
pero pero pasa Todavía que los médicos
utilizan instrumentos que las madres no
quieren que se utilicen para el
nacimiento de sus hijos o se sientan
encima de las madres y realizan estas
maniobras que son peligrosísimas y que
además pueden dejar a las madres con
temas de incontinencia pues para toda su
vida en el mejor de los casos Entonces
cómo cómo aprender nosotras a reconocer
cuando se nos están violentando nuestros
derechos porque uno tiende a seguir la
autoridad
en primer lugar yo haría el matiz de que
es cierto no que a menudo nos dicen que
tenemos que seguir todas estas
indicaciones porque hay un peligro y
sobre todo este peligro te marca en le
puede pasar algo muy malo a tu bebé pero
este argumento se desmonta en el momento
en que desgraciadamente y yo trato
también con muchas mujeres que han
vivido situaciones de duelo
perinatal en que su bebé ha fallecido
durante el embarazo con lo cual no hay
un bebé del cual haya que preservar su
salud y en su caso Tampoco se respetan
sus derechos ni se las informa De nada y
sufren las mismas intervenciones de
rutina que podrían ser consideradas
violencia obstétricas es decir cuando
tampoco está esta gran preocupación de
la salud no respetamos los derechos no
Entonces yo creo que aquí lo más
importante Por una parte Es que como
mujeres como usuarias nos informemos
podemos acudir asociaciones podemos leer
por nuestra cuenta podemos acudir a
grupos de madre sabemos que hay centros
que están intentando cambiar las cosas y
profesionales Buscar qué centros hay en
una persona que estén trabajando desde
ahí preguntar en organismos públicos ya
sea pues las consejerías de salud como
funcionen el lugar donde vivamos en las
administraciones públicas si hay
protocolos publicados Y si tienen
números o estadísticas de cada centro
pues por ejemplo respecto de cesáreas e
inducciones es decir desgraciadamente
tenemos que hacer un poco de uso de
nuestra agencia para saber tal vez donde
podamos potencialmente recibir un mejor
trato claro Mire no nos da el tiempo
para seguir hablando de los
fallecimientos prenatales que también es
una parte bien importante de esta
violencia obstétrica pero solo por citar
un ejemplo también me ponen a mujeres
que deben digamos tener partos Pese a
que sus hijos no llegarán al mundo con
vida y las ponen junto a las mujeres que
están recibiendo a sus bebés en buenas
condiciones de salud este tipo de
discriminaciones no deberían suceder y
ya para el cierre pues Marta lo que nos
queda es preocupación o porque todo eso
que usted describe esta necesidad de
Buscar que seamos bien atendidas y de
tener acceso a asociaciones y a médicos
que tengan un enfoque de género y un de
derechos pues lamentablemente también es
algo que se puede hacer cuando uno tiene
el privilegio y la posibilidad de
desplazarse o los medios para llegar a
un lugar que lo atienda uno como pues
pues como espera así que bueno quedamos
con estos grandes cuestionamientos que
afectan principalmente a las mujeres en
privación de la libertad y con este
precedente de que se da en octubre con
el pronunciamiento de la corte idh
gracias a usted Marta y a nuestros
televidentes por estar con nosotros una
vez más nos vemos Próximamente en ellas
hoy y en francés 24
[Música]